everyone pretend that you enjoy this
hairstyle than I am happening on my head
right now
hi guys and Eric help you do not know
now you know your life is different now
and it's Friday here on me it's great
YouTube channel and it's time to comment
on your mother in comments over color
ever heard of it Lulu Fortuna Bieber's
new program for all we do not know in a
new person comments on any of my social
media platforms like grace the crap out
of them and welcome them to the it's
grace family how do I know new person I
don't know I just guess aka everyone
that's new behaves people but now I
grace people's because I have been mean
when you can be done is that the whole
field was this feels real think that was
the spiel and we're stunned with this
feeling Lulu for to more like bathroom
bathroom 69 oh that's like the much more
perverted sexual version of engine
engine number nine although great pickup
line you guys are welcome to use that
you're on a plane you're far I'm 16 you
look good I felt like if you put the
geode in a sock before bashing it with a
hammer it contains all the shards and
then you have a handy weapon oh wow it
started off very helpful and then got
slightly scary at the end what a roller
coaster and it's not the only thing you
could put in a sack and bang and have
that sock contain all the shards talking
about wieners Elena tore a new member to
find Lana Tori more like Elena Corey I'm
old and this is a non relatable gesture
to most of you you've been gross thirty
thirty was such a fun movie I'm so glad
I finally watched it what a delightful
and straightforward and positive comment
Elena thank you so much if you guys want
to feel the glad that Elena is feeling
you should also watch dirty thirty
because Elena seems like the kind of
girl whose life is much better now
because she watched it so go get it I've
been spinning for a new person Dustin's
been affirmed on Dustin finisher dinner
that you're cooking for your lovely
girlfriend because she's on a long day
and you are a thoughtful thoughtful
boyfriend
and then finish her super gross just ate
cold leftover pad thai I like very
something for breakfast this morning
just thought the world should know this
is why Twitter exists also that sounds
amazing old leftover pad thai maybe
that's my stripper name
and I just come out wearing giant
shoulder pad yeah tied it would be
confused
dr. hill fire department her to knock up
hell fire more like fire your Magruder
oh you might like this horse onesie this
is awful
this is awful this is awful but this is
pretty sure what I look like to the rest
of the world now a credo Instagram ever
heard of it ha ha ha tabby cat 14 I'm a
super person if I'm tabby cat 14 MF more
like scabby back 50 in misses your look
right uh you have hotmail friends since
when someone is demanding a date I mean
I don't know I would say that they have
very average body temperatures this is
why I don't have many hotmail friends
haha a la ku barn different person from
my locker bar more like hell I'll occupy
a bot every damn day of every day super
rude juice juice is loose that sounds
disgusting
also goose has always been really great
about going to the bathroom outside
raised my daughter for her only skill it
doesn't involve murdering people Rebecca
Lowe new person person person Rebecca
Lowe more like Rebecca lower your
expectations on the types of
relationships you will have in your life
some people are not meant for good time
what bad backs to the world beauty in
the streets murder in the sheets
yeah that is the goose dog theme song
jitter on sitcom that would be the
opening song she lures people into a
false sense of safety and then
physically destroys them unlike her mom
who only does it emotionally any takers
on that set go through and mix 9 a new
person
firstly Dylan mix 9 8 more like villain
mix this 90 degrees track into something
that I can actually listen to I think
that might have been a genuine
subconscious want that's just snuck out
of my mouth sounds you're the worst
what would a sloth be like if it was as
fast as a cheetah a king nightmare
nobody we have ever heard of it karemera
new person person person Care Bear more
like don't care what consumer group as a
normal human being with a limited
wardrobe I appreciate the fact that
grace is one of the few youtubers who
actually rewear is the same shirt in
multiple video thank you for being so
wonderful understanding that I am a
garbage human and I live a sloppy sloppy
messy endlessly scumbag lifestyle
I am trash right now Garza new person
person person Reyna Garza more like rain
in the cars ah she got run over by the
car you're the food I haven't seen great
slap meat on her face that fast and she
was backstage at a Harry Styles concert
look he had a very very lovely shokudo
reboard at his craft services backstage
and I don't have self-control
so yeah it's lapses we are on my face
next to the Shakira board get over it
Rosie see new Frankie Murkin friend and
Rosie see more like Rosie see yeah kind
of an idiot you're rude who else is
watching without socks
let's go 619 legs on that comment I'm
left to believe 619 people had a big ol
suspect doing that video cool thanks
guys I appreciate it flattering
okay that's it for commenting on your
comments this week I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to this YouTube
channel because I make videos Monday
Wednesday and Friday
sometimes happy Memorial Day weekend be
safe do fun have good I don't know
am i doing the Fonz from Happy Days or
am i doing a hobo with cerebral palsy
are both of those offensive probably I
apologize